das ist ein bisschen
begeistert dass mir jetzt im Vergleich
zu Deutschland zum Beispiel also höflich
sind normalerweise beim stellen oder bin
ich auch
nein ich schrecklich ich finde das schön
wird und sagen dass Bier haben Kaffee
[Musik]
ich nehme den Kaffee bitte Bier
heute haben wir zu einer neuen Folge
und fragen wie Sprachen danke gleich
Zusammenhalt Barbara
es gibt ganz viele wunderschöne
Sachen
aktiv
also morgen und den Mörderin
ich habe besonders
[Musik]
was denn in versprochen an Mentalität
erwartet Befindlichkeit zu ausdrucken
oder das braucht wirklich ein Spiel
das messindustrieses Land und spekulativ
vor Verantwortung sind
eher indirekt als direkt ich glaube das
ist schon so wie Mentalitätsgeschichte
oder Kultur fragt wenn man es jetzt
verglichen
und das die Verhinderung
so alles klar
Schweizerinnen Wohnung
[Musik]
wie viel Frankreich
zu gestalten
genau
Schweiz aber eigentlich nicht
geschrieben obwohl natürlich die jüngere
Generation SMS chatten und so weiter
ich muss mir so viel überlegen ich finde
so komisch es gibt so viel Blut wo man
kein Buchstabe dafür hat und wird den
Schritt passt nicht
zum Beispiel der Rücken der Rücken ich
sage
ich Rücken wenn das Öl machst
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
also ich habe
Kollegen
sagt glaube
Schweizerdeutsch Text und Du darfst
einfach nicht lassen du musst eher so
fühlen was jetzt dort
überhaupt nicht ich glaube während
waren zum Beispiel also die ganze Idee
von Schweizerinnen
und das drückt irgendwie von der Kultur
und die Gemütlichkeit
übersetzen schwingt für das Mädchen
freut mich
jeden Tag ich weiß es nicht
ich weiß es nicht ich glaube sehr gut
vorstellen dass das wirklich stimmt
mich
gabi ist für mich
sagen
ich glaube das trifft wirklich der
Pragmatismus wo Twitter wirklich glauben
ohne großen Aufwand dass es stimmt und
das Wort gab also es gab sondern es
fällt mir und uns andere Wort und nicht
mehr so Favoritenliste würde ihnen aber
urkig im Urkunde die andere Schweiz
das das unbehandelte das Rohr der
knospital
genau das bürgerliche und
aber da wird ersetzt
schon sehr schlecht sehr gut muss ich
sagen für mich hat das schon immer große
Faszination zum Beispiel gefragt wieso
finden wir es
berichtend keine sprachliche
Unterscheidungen
also zum Beispiel Flora und Fauna
auseinanderhalten
ich sehe viele Grüße die Vielfalt wenn
ich mir begriffen und die Definition
unglaublich interessanter Punkt wenn du
mehr Sprache hast oder Sprache hast dann
nimmt er die Welt zur und du du nimmst
differenzierter Wort
oder eben wenn ich mit meiner Frau
unterwegs
erenzieren
es gibt sehr das schönste
Wort giacomos heißt Spiegelung vom Mond
auf dem Meer und sie ist unterwegs
wunderschönes Bild versprochen
bringe dann bringe ich Ihnen
gleichzeitig Gesetz vor der Physik wie
ich bin soziale Regie die alte Bischberg
Philosophie also der Quine und andere
früher betonte und das ist das nicht so
einfach so süß
funktioniert was ein Baum ist und unter
das waldwissen sondern dass das in den
anderen vermischt ist
interessanter Punkte
lehrend
das trifft ein bisschen so gut und zum
Beispiel aus dem deutschen
Italiener die Italiener quasi Heimweh
heißt
auch Kindergarten Kindergarten
sind zudem zu der Frage wie eigentlich
Wald und wahrnehmig und sprach zusammen
eigentlich aus Phänomen und das Unrecht
erst Wagner wurden nicht unbedingt
sensibler für unrechtssituationen
[Musik]
sprechen
Homosexualität und so weiter dass du
fast gespüren und wird sprachfindet den
Emotionen oder neige also das glaube ich
das stimmt schon alles es gibt einfach
Caroline Ehmke auch genau
wenn sie sagbar ist dann ist es auch wie
fühlbar oder normal anders fühlbar und
geht dann eine Eindeutigkeit mit dem
phänomenau umzko was sehr erleichtern
aber das kann eine Elektriker
ich würde mit dir gerne darüber reden
Schweiz
oder überhaupt
dass mir jetzt im Vergleich zu
Deutschland zum Beispiel also höflich
sind normalerweise beim stellen oder bin
ich auch
nein nicht schrecklich ich finde das
schön mir rufen und sagen dass Bier
haben
eventuell nein
ich kriege ein Bier ich finde das so das
ist schon etwas
hier ich finde das viel schöner das
ja mit dem Kopf
die ganze Konflikt Kultur von
Schweizerinnen und schweizerisch nicht
ausgeprägt und vieles immer danach
sprechen gefunden
kontrollierst ja fälschlicherweise immer
aufgrund von Christina Konventionen aber
die anderen Frauen
[Gelächter]
versucht freundliche sprachliche Umgang
miteinander
sprach und das andere zendet
ExpertInnen und Experte in Sachen
abonniert doch der Kanal